bonsoir et bienvenue si vous venez de
nous rejoindre pour le 7-8 politique
c'est la reprise en ce mois de septembre
pour l'émission politique de téléphiles
tous les mois nous allons revenir avec
nos invités sur les différents sujets
d'actualité avec des élus des
responsables locaux il sera forcément
aujourd'hui est question des régionales
avec le scrutin de décembre qui approche
je recevrai tout à l'heure olivier
paréja le co secrétaire départemental
d'europe écologie les verts dans les
yvelines mais le premier invité de ce
numéro du 7-8 politique de la saison
michel laugier
bonsoir et bienvenue en plateau
président à divers droite de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maire de
montigny le bretonneux
on va évoquer forcément l'avenir de
l'intercommunalité 1er janvier cinq
nouvelles communes qui vont rejoindre
saint quentin en yvelines ou alors ses
50 ans qui rejoint les autres communes
en tout cas ce sera une nouvelle interco
qui va naître
auparavant on va revenir sur quelques
uns des sujets d'actualités locales du
mois écoulé la ligne 18 par exemple pour
débuter il ya un collectif qui s'était
organisé à voisins le bretonneux ils
sont contre le passage de la ligne 18
sous leur commune et plus précisément au
quartier de la bretonnière à la ligne 18
c'est celle du grand paris et qui va
relier dans une quinzaine d'années orly
et versailles chantiers en passant donc
par saint quentin en yvelines
est ce que vous les soutenez est ce que
vous les comprenez alors bien sûr que je
les comprends sauf que je pense que l'on
va trouver une solution rapidement tout
simplement le tracé de l'es18 a été
bonifié puisque dans un premier temps on
devait avoir deux gars sur saint quentin
ne devons plus qu'une et donc le je
pense qu'on a quand même toutes les
possibilités de demander la sucer le
grand paris de modifier le parcours
surtout sur la fin on entend quand on va
plonger à hauteur du golfe et donc à mon
avis la ligne de métro ne passera pas
sous loisel moteur
quelle marge de négociation vous avez
pour l'intercours justement avec la
société du grand paris un échange qui
est possible où on vous impose les
choses parce que c'est un bon jeu
véritablement important pour les
dizaines d'années à venir cette ligne on
nous oppose les choses je dirais que je
crois que ce sont surtout les moyens
financiers ils sont à disposition qui
nous imposent de certaines
vision donc là la cité du grand paris
travail sauf que c'est très encadré
c'est une loi et donc on a on a une
marge une marge où on peut effectivement
agir et s'entendre donc là aujourd'hui a
lancé qu'il y a qu une seule gardons
notre but aujourd'hui notre volonté
notre objectif c'est de faire de cette
gare en véritable pôle multimodal
donc ça c'est notre ambition et puis
ensuite il ya encore quelques personnes
qui militent aussi pour le passage en
souterrain plutôt qu'en mai rien mais là
aussi ce sont uniquement des problèmes
de budget
l'enquêté publique débutera en début
d'année prochaine après les élections
régionales
et donc on y verra plus clair un petit
peu plus tard on attendra donc le début
de l'année prochaine d'autres sujets
dans l'actualité ces dernières semaines
c'est la question de l'accueil des
réfugiés ces réfugiés venus de syrie
venus d'irak
certaines communes comme la verrière se
sont proposés pour les recevoir est ce
qu'il y aura une politique commune
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines sur l'accueil des réfugiés
alors d'une part ce n'est pas dans les
compétences de l'agglo beauté
nation qui n'a pas non plus d'équipement
pour pouvoir héberger par contre ils
l'emmenaient il en va de la
responsabilité de chacun des maires de
chacun des maires des sept communes de
saint quentin en yvelines de savoir ce
qu'il souhaite faire dont l'afrique
concernant signer les conventions de
montigny nous comme l'a toujours fait a
toujours été solidaire chaque fois qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose dans le monde
les émeutiers ont toujours été solidaire
donc moi toutes les familles qui
souhaitent accueillir des réfugiés
elles sont les bienvenus et bien sûr la
ville mettra à disposition
l'accompagnement qu'il faut notamment
pour la scolarisation des enfants pour
les enfants dans les crèches donc y aura
cet accompagnement une famille de
montigny est venu m'a présenté aussi une
famille qu'elle accueillait bon pour
avoir un petit peu est la marche à
suivre sauf que cette famine ne voulais
pas rester en france et pourrait faire à
partir en allemagne à l'heure après bon
je suis aussi en contact avec le curé de
monter mais aussi qui veut bien agir
donc voila tout les veaux des bonnes
volontés sont là maintenant quand les
réfugiés si ça va refuser veulent venir
habiter montini et bien nous les
accompagnons le monde comme ils le font
et d'ailleurs on a eu aussi quelques
réfugiés mais pas que de manque pas que
sur le territoire de montigny et sur les
yvelines puisque nous avons été quand
même la première commune de france a
organisé une messe en arabe sont avérées
tient d'orient donc l'évêque des
marronniers de france était présent avec
l'évêque de versailles et donc on a pu
voir aussi la générosité à monter on va
continuer à profiter de ce premier
numéro de l'année du 7-8 politique pour
évoquer avec vous quelques uns des
sujets qui concerne l'agglomération pas
que l'agglomération mais en tout cas
l'agglomération est aussi concerné c'est
la question des diminution des dotations
de l'état des dotations financières de
l'état aux différentes communes - 30 %
en moyenne
il ya eu plusieurs mobilisation des élus
parce que ça veut dire tout simplement
moins d'argent dans les caisses il va
falloir faire des économies en tout cas
ce que vous êtes inquiet pour ces
communes et donc pour saint quentin en
yvelines aussi pose la question à la
fois en tant que maire pour montigny et
puis aussi en tant que président de
l'agglomération
on ne peut qu'être riquet et puis vous
je suis aussi inquiet en tant que les
conseillers département cette année
également des par exemple je rappelle
simplement que le département des
yvelines va perdre 120 millions
d'euros en trois ans la communauté
d'agglomération va perdre 15 millions
d'euros en trois ans la ville de
montigny perd plus d'un million et demi
par an a encore aussi pendant les deux
prochaines années qui vont venir
donc c'est vrai que c'est un vrai
problème c'est un des problèmes l'état
aujourd'hui bien sûr explique que tous
les français que les impôts vont
diminuer
c'est sûr que quand on se désengage je
donne un côté c'est beaucoup plus facile
dire que les impôts pour les habitants
au global ne vont pas diminuer
et si c'est ici à des missions sont
hollandais bref or c'est maintenant il
ya des grillades et collectivités qui
vont se rattraper d'ailleurs vous allez
bien vu il ya plein de villes en france
guillon procéder à des augmentations
nous aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout notre
vision des choses sur mon tennis je n'ai
pas augmenter les impôts et sur 50 ans
des lignes je n'ai pas nous n'avons pas
souhaité augmenter aussi les impôts donc
c'est pas aux habitants de devoir disons
être les responsables de la du
désengagement de l'état
donc c'est donc agronomie sur les
différentes compétences et bien gêne à
parler de l'agglo bien sûr nous avouent
né pas d'autres quand vous avez moins de
boya vous faites moins donc dans votre
budget personnel vous avez moins de
moyens eh bien vous faites moins de
sorties au restaurant vous allez -
théâtre cette semaine il y aura la
réunion du conseil communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines justement la
rentrée aussi pour vous en dehors de
l'élargissement de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines on va y venir
quelles sont vos priorités pour cette
année les priorités pour cette année
déjà bon cd exécuter le budget que nous
avons voté pour l'année 2015 mais déjà
des temps préparation pour l'année 2016
et l'a déjà bas c'est la préoccupation
vous l'avait dit et on doit encore
trouver 5 millions supplémentaires
d'économies par rapport à l'année
dernière où déjà on avait été obligé de
faire des coupes sombres
donc voilà la préoccupation elle est là
elle n'est pas dans l'exécution que
j'avais des idées des pistes justement
pour procéder à ces économies nous avons
des pistes c'est à dire qu'on va encore
réduire notre train de vie en étant
moins de faire encore des économies
on est en train de mutualiser certains
services on va libérer des équipements
et et donc du coup on va vendre
patrimoine dont on n'a plus besoin
donc ça c'est le travail au quotidien
que l'on doit faire mais malgré ça il ya
aussi de belles réussites on travaille
encore très fort avec le monde
économique on essaie d'avoir de
nouvelles entreprises qui viennent
s'installer de 7000 entreprises et cent
mille salariés en sorte que ça fait
longtemps qu'ils font a précisé c'est
parce que c'est parce que ce sont dix
mille salariés
donc il ya une année encore des mille de
plus et là on travaille encore bon ne
serait ce que dans les dernières
semaines ont eu de très bonnes nouvelles
avec la vente de l'immeuble
internationale le rachat aussi de
l'immeuble de l'insee au ciné qui était
vie de la laver avec eux aussi l'arrivée
de l'estaca même il faut aussi à
l'ingénieur fier d'avoir d'une école
d'ingénieurs qui s'est installée à ma
montini mais sur quel même sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines
et tout ça pour venir travailler avec
les filières automobile aéronautique qui
sont déjà présentes sur notre territoire
est aussi en lien avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin
donc c'est quand même très très fort et
on est très heureux d'avoir cette école
l'économie dossiers importants il ya
beaucoup de dossiers importants pour
l'agglomération et puis il ya surtout
cette refonte de l'intercommunalité que
tout ça va changer de visage en janvier
nos repas à coignières plaisir
villepreux elle les clés est ce que vous
discutez j'imagine avec ses différentes
communes aujourd'hui est ce que vous
êtes plus ou moins d'accord sur le
projet à quoi va ressembler la future
intercommunalité
alors déjà cerne les compétences tu as
fait d'être sont les preuves avancées
dînatoire qui a bien sûr alors que ça
sort on travaille déjà depuis plusieurs
beaux ensemble parce que on n'a pas se
mettre là autour d'une table d'autant
qu' il faut que tout soit voté avant le
15 décembre
puisque la nouvelle intercommunalité se
mettre en place au 1er janvier donc
c'est pas saint quentin qui absorbe
d'autres communes c'est la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin la
communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien c'est à dire plaisir les clés
villepreux ainsi que les communes de
coignières de maurepas qui vont créer
une nouvelle intercommunalité
ça changera non a priori et pour le
moment je n'en ai pas encore ce v6 a
plus que le nom va trouver les choses
seraient alors ce qui veut dire que
c'est pas si simple que ça donc les
tensions là si simple que ça parce que
dès aujourd'hui on est en train de
revoir les coller
compétences avec les communes historique
avec les communes nouvelles et donc on
travaille là dessus mais on a eu un bon
rythme de travail et je pense qu'à ce
jour on a réglé déjà 95 % des choses
quels sont les 5% qui bloque même si
j'imagine que vous énoncez question donc
vous allez me dire ce soir meilleur ce
soir mais ce sont surtout en plus ce
sont surtout sur des compétences
facultatives
voilà donc après c'est une appréciation
que l'on a de certaines choses mais on
va dire que les grands les grands
problèmes ont été en trouver une
solution et que en avant ce très bien
sur la réorganisation politique cette
fois ci sur les postes de chacun parce
qu'il va y avoir forcément des
réaménagements il y aura une nouvelle
élection pour la présidence et l'aimta
fait tout à fait sûrs y serait candidat
je serai candidat bien sûr donc il y
aura une nouvelle organisation un nouvel
exécutif est effectivement avec cinq
communes supplémentaires aux n'a pas
droit non plus avoir beaucoup plus de
vice-président donc il y aura il ya des
négociations actuellement pour savoir
quel est le meilleur le juste équilibre
entre toutes les communes donc là on
travaille aussi sur ce qu'on appelle la
gouvernance ça c'est le côté gouvernance
qui concerne prioritairement on va dire
les habitants de saint quentin et puis
dès les communes qui vont qui vont
rejoindre saint quentin c'est le
quotidien qu'est ce que ça va changer au
quotidien et ce qui aura des bénéfices
dans cette union
alors des bêtises dans cette union oui
c'est dire est que ono ride intégralité
qui serait plus puissante
on va asseoir encore plus notre
positionnement économique
on va devenir le premier pôle commercial
du département des idées évident bien
sûr mais dans le top 5 dans la région
ile de france
on va bien sûr renforcer notre position
de deuxième pôle économique après la
défense on va voir un territoire qui
n'aura plus trois gars mais cette gare
d'ouvriers ce sont des choses
importantes et donc après tout le
travail
on va essayer de 2
d'avoir un lien entre les différents
points du territoire notamment sur les
transports en commun donc les choses
vont évoluer sans aucun problème et les
habitants vont s'en rendre compte
la seule chose aussi qu'il faut dire
c'est que on fera ça aussi avec moi de
capacités financières mais peut-être dès
que plus d'idées et d'efficacité et nous
suivrons bien évidemment tout ça d'ici
la fin de l'année nous verrons quels
sont les bénéfices ou non pour les
différents habitants de ces communes
nous verrons comment va s'organiser
cette nouvelle agglomération dans les
prochaines semaines merci à michel
laugier un tout dernier mot les
élections régionales c'est en décembre
la campagne plus que lancé valérie
pécresse chef de file de la droite et du
centre
elle va s'imposer écoutez je pense que
valérie aujourd'hui et l'abbaye rue
candidate est en tout cas elle a tout
mon soutien
merci justement nous ouvrons à présent
une large page dédiée aux régionales les
candidats qui sont plus qu'en campagne
et les meetings se multiplient valérie
pécresse justement à lancer vraiment sa
campagne dimanche dernier 27 septembre
avec tous les ténors de la droite et du
centre à ses côtés c'était à paris
présente sur le terrain depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et multipliait
les attaques contre la majorité
socialiste sortante menée aujourd'hui
par claude bartolone ce mois de
septembre dans son viseur et celui de
ses alliés la gestion des lycées ou
encore le transport les transports
écouter david douillet revenir sur la
mise en place du pass navigo à 70 euros
pour tous voilà son avis un pass navigo
à tarif unique
pourquoi pas la gratuité
total dans les transports parisiens j'en
rêve on n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui
la taille fait que la tarification
unique du passe navigo qui comme par
hasard tombe là à quelques mois avant
l'élection comme par hasard
pour moi c'est une décision c'est de
l'irresponsabilité politique pourquoi
parce qu'elle n'est pas financé
aujourd'hui monsieur bartolone avec
monsieur qu'elle fonde cherche le moyen
de financer ces 200 millions d'euros qui
manquent
le bilan après dix sept années de
gestion régionale par les socialistes
il est catastrophique sur tous les
niveaux mais en particulier au niveau
des transports et à l'ump qui pourra
aussi compter sur les voix du modem
après lui des lycées la formation de
françois bayrou qui vient de conclure un
accord national avec les républicains un
risque pour la survie de son parti pour
certains l'assurance d'obtenir quelques
élus quelle que soit l'issue de ce
scrutin pour d'autres du côté du ps à
présent on se met à rêver d'une grande
alliance à gauche
un référendum sera proposée mi octobre
sur la pertinence de s'allier entre le
ps pc les écologistes mais pour le
moment c'est seul que claude bartolone
mène sa campagne en ile de france il est
venu dans les yvelines en ce mois de
septembre visiter le site de l'inra où
se trouvent des ingénieurs agricoles il
est venu observer à l'avancée des
recherches dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire et surtout de défendre
le bilan de ses prédécesseurs jean paul
huchon en tête
et naturellement on en revient à la
question du développement des transports
on voit les différents outils qui sont
ceux de la région sur lequel il faut
activer utiliser le bilan de jean paul
huchon pour aller plus loin et l'on voit
bien sur la réflexion de ce que peut
être le métro du grand paris ce que
représenterait la desserte de saclay et
pourquoi pas de versailles et de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines si comme je le
souhaite
nous obtenons les jeux olympiques de
2024 pour le front national la rentrée
aura été délicate pour le candidat
avaleront de saint-just lui
aussi trésorier du front national a été
mis en examen pour recel d'abus de biens
sociaux dans la sphère de financement de
son parti elle reste que dans les
derniers sondages sa formation pourrait
atteindre les 18 % sur ces régionales
donc en ile de france
il joue donc les trouble fête et pendant
ce temps nicolas dupont aignan toujours
selon ce même sondage de l'ifop
atteindrait les 7% est les voix du
candidat de debout la france pourrait
donc peser lourd sur le second tour
nicolas dupont aignan qui vient
d'annoncer le ralliement de jean claude
delarue c'est le président de sos
usagers associations d'utilisateurs des
transports en commun franciliens qui
souhaitait également concourir dans ce
scrutin voilà pour ce tour d'horizon à
rapide de cette campagne dont les
yvelines plus particulièrement pour la
présidence de la région ile de france on
va s'intéresser à la situation d'europe
écologie les verts à présent avec vous
olivier paréja bonsoir et bienvenue
corré secrétaire dans les yvelines de
cette formation
je reste juste sur le sondage que je
donnais tout à l'heure 7,5 pour cent
selon l'ifop pour europe écologie les
verts aux régionales derrière le parti
communiste est ce que c'est une bonne
mauvaise nouvelle c'est une très très
mauvaise nouvelle mais c'est pas tout à
fait illogique
à l'heure actuelle le ce dont on entend
parler dans les médias sur les
écologistes sont plutôt des dissensions
on n'a pas encore vu le temps de
développer notre programme et donc c'est
en présentant deux programmes que
nécessairement on va arriver à
convaincre les gens sur le bilan de ce
qui a été fait pendant la mandature qui
s'achève
et puis les propositions qu'on fait pour
l'avenir donc aujourd'hui c'est pas
nécessairement inquiétant d'avoir un
score aussi peu élevé même s'il faudra
aller vite parce que le scrutin c'est
demain presqu'un s'aidant de la mi
décembre
il ya eu cette idée aussi d'un
référendum qui a été lancé pour demander
aux militants de gauche s'il faut ou non
une alliance de la gauche aux régionales
idée lancée par le ps et mi-octobre et
on va pouvoir aller voter pour décider
si oui ou non la gauche loi doit s'unir
sur les différentes régions c'est une
fausse bonne idée
ma vraie bonne idée l'idée de s'allier
de rassembler la gauche est plutôt
enthousiasmante
on est pour on a clairement dit que au
second tour on était pour un
rassemblement de toute la gauche
simplement faut se mettre d'accord sur
quel programme et pour quoi faire
donc la question est ce que vous l'êtes
rassemblé oui non on peut répondre il
m'aimait rassemblés pour quoi faire
donc la question le référendum en soi
est déjà une façon de simplifier le
débat mais alors là la question est
particulièrement mal posé pourtant il ya
des propositions qui sont faites par le
parti socialiste dans lesquelles vous
pourriez vous retrouver claude bartolone
qui parle d'écotaxe par exemple comme ça
fait mal ce quelque chose tout à fait
manuel cause pareil exactement
mais yahia nécessairement des choses sur
lesquelles on va être d'accord y'a pas
il ya des choses sur lesquelles on n'a
pas nécessairement la même vision alors
qu'est ce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
justement pourquoi dès le premier tour
il n'y a pas eu une alliance je pense
qu'il ya quand même des choses de
politiques qui sont différentes on
entendait claude bartolone par exemple
méditer pour les jeux olympiques alors
que nous on peut penser que c'est une
dépense qui est peut-être un petit peu
excessive et c'est peut-être pas la
priorité
par les temps qui courent dans la région
ile de france en particulier où il ya
énormément d'inégalités donc il ya des
choses de ce type là sur les transports
j'entendais michel laugier être très
content ce de delà de la ligne 18 qui va
défier à 151 m
mais l'on peut se poser la question est
ce que cette ligne est justifiée par
rapport aux besoins et pour quel
urbanisation c'est à dire que il est
évident que la l'urbanisation actuelle
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de ses
environs ne justifie pas une ligne de
métro automatique
le but c'est de se projeter aussi pour
avoir toutes les infrastructures
nécessaires à l'avenir
vimeo le développement du secteur arrive
paris saclay en ligne de mire bien sûr
bien sûr mais est ce que ça veut dire
consommer les terres agricoles qu'on a
sur le plateau de saclay elles sont
sanctuarisés aujourd'hui il faut se
battre pour les garder dans le programme
écologique par exemple à la région il
est évident que il y aura quelque chose
sur l'agriculture de proximité sur
l'agriculture en ville parce que demain
avec les objectifs qu'on se donne par
rapport aux émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on est à deux mois de la coop
il va falloir quand même que y ait des
choses qui changent si on veut rester en
dessous des 2 degrés au dessus duquel on
sait pas trop ce que peut devenir la
terre
les catastrophes qu'on pourrait avoir de
dérèglement climatique
donc si on veut rester en dessous de ces
2 degrés il ya des choses qui doivent
changer et en particulier ses
relocaliser la production relocaliser
l'agriculture et surtout ne pas
consommer les terres agricoles qu'on a
aujourd'hui qui sont fertiles et qui
sont près de chez nous pour en faire
pour en faire de l'urbanisation
supplémentaires ça c'est pour les
différents points de programmes qui
seront abordés on imagine vous êtes en
train de peaufiner le programme où on
imagine aussi de vous pour finn et les
listes parce qu'elles sont pas encore
définitives est-ce que vous par exemple
vous serez candidat pour le département
des yvelines
donc les listes sont en train d'être
construites donc les têtes de liste ont
déjà été annoncés donc par exemple dans
les yvelines mounir satouri emmènera la
liste des yvelines avec des écologistes
avec des personnes de cap21 puisqu'il ya
un accord pour c'est pour ces élections
régionales
et donc on est en train de constituer le
reste de la liste est un il ya un
conseil ce soir qui se réunit à nouveau
de la région ce soir pour savoir
exactement
je vous propose d'écouter un micro
trottoir à présent vous les avez évoqué
au début de cet entretien ses
différentes tensions qui ont fait
l'actualité autour d'europe écologie et
les verts alors qu'attendez-vous de
cette formation politique
qu'attendez-vous d'europe écologie les
verts nous vous avons posé la question
je suis très écologie oui je pour
l'environnement je suis membre des
associations pour les animaux pour le
wwf tout ça donc moi si ça peut faire un
parti où quelque chose qui puisse donner
des voix samaoui j'aime bien qu'il
remplisse sa mission d' écologie comme
son nom l'indiqué ce que pour l'instant
on n'a pas vu trop de haut je n'ai pas
eu en tout cas moi personnellement j'ai
pas vu d'action concrète mais et puis
que ça soit parti citoyen aussi ils
travaillent dans ce dans le sens pour
l'intérêt du bien commun et non pour des
intérêts individuels sur tout mais c'est
que je pense qu'ils ont pas quelques
farizon pas une politique très fin est
ce que ça peut vraiment jouer dans les
politiques actuelles je pense que c'est
une bonne politique et parce que ça a
jouera sur le futur mais en soit je sais
pas si si politiquement parlant ils ont
vraiment un bon truc économique fait que
de l'écologie non vous avez d'autres
propositions aussi devraient réagir sur
ce qu'il fait tout à fait non par
exemple une des propositions qui est
clair c'est sur le logement continuer ce
qui a été fait dans la mandature ac
ul emmanuelle cosse qui ne tête de liste
pour les régionales était
vice-présidente au logement de la région
ile de france et il a été investi 1,2
milliard sur le logement pour essayer de
réduire les inégalités qui sont
extrêmement importantes en ile de france
et donc typiquement l'idée est de
continuer il ya des choses alors donc la
personne ne le sait pas nécessairement
donc ça va être notre travail dans les
semaines à venir de l'expliquer mais
donc sur le logement il ya des choses
qui ont été faites sur le passe navigo
par exemple qu'on entendait david
douillet qui n'y trouvais que c'était
pas financé mais n'empêche que il ya 10%
de personnes en plus en septembre qui
ont pris un pass navigo
donc c'est extrêmement important que les
gens utilisent plus les transports en
commun donc ça c'est des choses qui ont
été faites et on va continuer dans ce
sens là on a énormément de propositions
qui ont déjà été communiqués sur les
transports par exemple sur le fait
d'avoir des tickets qui soit valable
une heure trente qui soit valable
également dans les bulls et des choses
qui vont permettre à toute une série de
propositions je vous internet justin
excusez moi mais que le temps passe et
choix comme vous faire réagir sur ces
tensions qui eux au sein d'europe
écologie les verts parce qu'on l'a
entendu aussi dans le micro trottoir
il faut pas que le parti servent comme
dans les autres formations ceci dit à
des intérêts des ambitions personnelles
il ya eu les départs de jean vincent
placé de françois de rugy aussi ils ont
même lancé un mouvement d'ailleurs un le
mouvement écologiste tout à fait un coup
dur nécessairement s'il ya des gens qui
partent ne peut pas être quelque chose
de sympathique
donc en plus des gens avec qui on a
milité pendant plusieurs années donc il
ya un problème mais ça va aussi donner
une clarification
parce que le on va se recentrer par
exemple dans les yvelines
il n'y a absolument aucune démission les
gens sont des militants qui sont
concentrées sur l'écologie qui ont
oublié de faire avancer les choses qui
sont concentrées sur l'école jean
vincent placé 10 et un astre mort europe
ecologie les verts mais peut-être pour
sa progression vers un ministère parler
d'elle sa recherche est peut-être une
comète qui l'emmènerait dans un
ministère
mais sur le terrain les gens qui sont
militants d'europe écologie verts sont
aussi dans les associations sont aussi
dans les villes en transition ont
participé à tous les alternatives qui
ont lieu dans les yvelines
et là il ya des vrais mobilisation qui
est qu'il faut accompagner et europe
ecologie les verts a vocation à être le
bras politique de ces gens là où jours
on n'est peut-être pas reconnu comme tel
mais je pense qu'il va y avoir vraiment
une clarification et se recentrer sur
vraiment faire de l'écologie proposer
des choses pour cette région qui est
inégalitaire au possible entre iliad et
ya des revenus moyens entre les communes
d'ile-de-france qui peuvent de 1 à 5
il ya 1,4 million de personnes qui sont
sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est des
choses sur lesquelles il faut
concrètement agir et agir c'est par
exemple lutter contre le la précarité
énergétique les gens qui ne peuvent pas
se chauffer il ya je ne sais plus
combien 360 ou 370000 personnes en ile
de france donc c'est vraiment sur ces
projets là que europe ecologie les verts
doit se faire entendre et que on arrête
un peu parlé de problèmes de personnes
qui sont quand même très centré sur
quelques personnes qui ne touchent pas
toute la france qui ne touche pas les
yvelines je les dis mais qui ne touche
que très très peu de gens en général tu
es sans visière toute dernière question
là ça touche au programme on parle pas
des personnes au sein du parti sur des
propositions que vous pouvez mettre
comme l'interdiction complète du diesel
en france est une idée que vous portez
qui est porté par la secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
c'est pas très réaliste si ce n'est pas
nécessairement pour demain mais l'idée
c'est sacré populaire non plus mais dans
ce plan explique 70 c'est quand même 70
% du parc automobile français mais le je
vous ai dit on a mobilisé 1,2 milliard
pour le logement alors qu'on en avait
promis un cette fois ci on parle de 3
milliards pour améliorer là pour lutter
contre la pollution de l'air en
ile-de-france donc en particulier aider
les ménages qui en ont besoin aider les
artisans à aller vers des voitures plus
propres et donc ça ça contribue à rendre
possible le fait d'imaginer un jour se
passer du diesel mais le rôle des
pouvoirs publics le lot le rôle du
législateur s'est donné la direction à
long terme dont d'expliquer qu' à terme
le diesel n'est pas nécessairement le
bienvenu donc vous ne l'avez dit ce sera
votre mission pour les prochaines
semaines avant les élections régionales
merci beaucoup olivier paréja d'europe
écologie les verts d'être venu nous
refermons donc ce 7,8 politique rendez
vous fin octobre pour le prochain numéro
l'actualité de la campagne des
régionales c'est bien sûr à suivre
régulièrement dans nos éditions du
journal du lundi au vendredi très belle
soirée